I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE OSCAR
FOR BEST ACTRESS.
THE ACADEMY HAS RECOGNIZED SOME
OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCES THIS YEAR.
25 YEARS AGO SHE MADE HER BROADWAY
DEBUT IN AN AUGUST WILSON PLAY.
TONIGHT, VIOLA DAVIS IS
NOMINATED FOR BRINGING TO LIFE
ANOTHER OF THAT GREAT AMERICAN
PLAYWRIGHT'S WORK, AS THE LEAD
ACTRESS IN "MA RAINEY'S BLACK
BOTTOM."
YOU WERE LUMINOUS IN THAT ROLE,
VIOLA.
ANDRA DAY, IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
"THE UNITED STATES VS. BILLIE HOLIDAY"
IS YOUR FIRST MAJOR FILM ROLE.
YOU SEAMLESSLY EMBODIED THE
ICON, AND REMINDED US THAT
BILLIE HOLIDAY WAS A SURVIVOR
AND A FIGHTER.
VANESSA KIRBY, YOU WENT THERE
FOR YOUR PERFORMANCE IN
"PIECES OF A WOMAN."
WHICH IS WHY YOUR PEERS HAVE
RECOGNIZED THIS FEARLESS AND
VULNERABLE PERFORMANCE.
FRANCES MCDORMAND, IN THIS
UNTETHERED MOMENT, WE NEEDED
YOUR PERFORMANCE IN "NOMADLAND."
YOU TOOK US INTO A WORLD HIDING
IN PLAIN SIGHT WITH CHARISMA AND
TRANSPARENCY.
CAREY MULLIGAN, YOU KNEW THE
RISK YOU WERE TAKING WITH
"PROMISING YOUNG WOMAN."
CONGRATULATIONS ON A PERFORMANCE
THAT WAS PAINFUL, WITTY, AND
POWERFUL.
AND THE BEST OSCAR FOR BEST
ACTRESS GOES TO --
FRANCES MCDORMAND, "NOMADLAND."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪
LOOK, THEY DIDN'T ASK ME.
BUT IF THEY HAD, I WOULD HAVE
SAID, KARAOKE. BECAUSE,
WHEN YOU HAVE VOICES LIKE LESLIE
AND MARCUS AND -- WE SHOULD ADD
A KARAOKE BAR.
OKAY?
I HAVE NO WORDS.
MY VOICE IS IN MY SWORD.
WE KNOW THE SWORD IS OUR WORK.
AND I LIKE WORK.
THANK YOU FOR KNOWING THAT.
AND THANKS FOR THIS.
[ APPLAUSE ]